it's great to be with you tonight we're
going to have not a lecture exactly but
a discussion or a lecture with
discussion about one moral dilemma that
looms very large in our society today
it's the subject of the new book the
question is simple to state but not so
easy to answer what role should money
and markets play in our society today
there are very few things that money
can't buy if you happen ever to be
convicted to a jail sentence in Santa
Barbara California just in case you
might you might like to know that if you
don't like the standard accommodations
you can buy a prison cell upgrade
how much do you suppose it costs any one
fifty two hundred and fifty it's eighty
two dollars a night or suppose you want
to contribute to the alleviation of a
tragic social ill the birth each year of
thousands of babies two drug-addicted
women there's a charity you can
contribute to that tries to address this
problem by offering a three hundred
dollar cash incentive to any
drug-addicted woman willing to be
sterilized a market incentive or suppose
you're a college student you want to
make some cash there are advertisers who
are looking for advertising space on
your forehead a few years ago a London
ad agency began recruiting college
students to wear tattoo
and on their foreheads for a company
logo is that kind of thing now these
were temporary tattoos they were willing
to pay each student four pounds 20 an
hour to display the ads one potential
sponsor praised the idea saying that the
forehead ads were an extension of the
sandwich board but a bit more organic
and some have taken this idea further
there was one woman a single mother who
needed money to support the education of
her son who auctioned off for ten
thousand dollars access on her forehead
to any company willing to pay $10,000
the winning bid came from an online
casino and unbe hold she now carries a
permanent tattoo ad for the online
casino the past three decades have seen
a quiet revolution almost without
realizing it we've drifted from having a
market economy to becoming a market
society the difference is this a market
economy is a tool a valuable and
effective tool for organizing productive
activity the market society is different
it's a place where almost everything is
up for sale it's a way of life where
market values seep into almost every
domain of life now there are some things
money can't buy even if it tries
friendship for example suppose you want
more friends than you have you've not
succeeded in acquiring them in the usual
way it might occur to you might occur to
you to buy some but then you would
probably quickly realize that it
wouldn't work but why not
it's in
interesting philosophical question why
it wouldn't work but somehow we sense
that a higher trend a bot friend is not
the same as the real thing somehow the
money that would buy the good dissolves
the very thing we're aiming at
there are many goods that money can buy
but arguably shouldn't and there are
lots of intermediate cases consider
expressions of friendship wedding toasts
how many here one time or another have
been asked to give a wedding toast at a
friend's wedding more than a handful now
for some this can be an anxiety inducing
request it isn't easy to write an
eloquent and moving and funny wedding
toast today there's help if you don't
feel you're very good at writing a
wedding toast for your friend you can
buy one online one of these websites
that offers them for sale is called the
perfect toast com you go online you
enter some information about the couple
how they met how you came to know them
whether you want a funny wedding toast
or a tearjerker and within three
business days they will send you a
custom written wedding toast
for how much do you suppose ten dollars
fifty this is a custom-made wedding tote
it's 149 dollars including shipping and
handling now a wedding toast then is
something that money can buy online for
149 dollars but is it the is it as good
as an authentic wedding toast here's one
way of testing this suppose at your
wedding your best friend
delivered a moving wedding toast so
moving that it brought tears to your
eyes and then later you learned that he
or she had bought it online how would
you feel would the wedding toast have
less value less meaning once you learned
that what would you say yeah probably
yes
no you wouldn't care you're not in the
business by any chance huh
why would it mean less well in a way
it's sort of like the friendship case
when you discover that money has bought
the thing somehow the value and meaning
of it is diminished not completely
especially if you don't know about it
but it's somehow degraded the meaning is
eroded by the purchase and sale and this
is true of many goods and social
practices and it's worth thinking about
why how this happens exactly and what
should be the consequences for the use
we make of market mechanisms of buying
and selling take books now books have
always been commodities in a way market
goods in the sense that you can't walk
in into a bookshop and walk out with the
book you have to pay for it so books are
market goods but only up to a point you
can see this if you consider the
practice of product placement it's
familiar in movies and in television
shows but
we don't normally see product placement
in books until recently the novelist Fay
Weldon viewer dove her well-known
novelist a few years ago she entered
into a deal with Bulgari jewelry company
to write a novel with paid product
placement she agreed to mention Bulgari
at least a dozen times in exchange for a
fee in her novel
the title of her book aptly enough was
the Bulgari connection and she exceeded
the required number of product
references mentioning Bulgari 34 times
now some critics complained about the
clunkiness the product Laden prose I'll
read you a line of the dialogue you'll
see what I mean
quote a Bulgari necklace in the hand is
worth two in the bush said Doris
or here's another one they snuggled
together happily for a bit all passion
spent and she met him at Bulgari that
lunchtime
fortunately product placement in books
has not really caught on but I suspect
that the experience of reading will be
brought in closer and closer proximity
to commercial advertising with the
advent in the growing prominence of
digital readers electronic readers last
year Amazon
issued two versions of its popular
Kindle reader one of them is the
standard version and the other for 40
dollars less you can buy the same kindle
provided you're willing to have
commercial ads running on the homepage
and on the screen saver would it be
worth it for $40.00 nominee would go for
that deal a few people would some of the
younger people in the audience